oh yeah this is a Gundam neighborhood
yeah think I'm styling a bit so since we
got here we've been like dude it's such
an old reference now Shh good morning
guys it's the third day in Korea and
today it's actually very cool we get to
do we get to experience k-beauty and we
get to learn about gay beauty and like
the importance of it in Korea and
actually around the world cuz it's a
very popular thing so this event that
was organized with multiple people from
around the world everyone got to split
up into different themes and so we got
the kpop k-beauty theme and we picked
that one because we thought it would be
really fun for Isaac to kind of just see
what kpop is all about and then for me I
really wanted to learn more about
k-beauty too so we're gonna get to do
that today
all right so first stop of the day is at
some class soon which I hope I'm
pronouncing properly but apparently this
is a very high-end Korean beauty brand
and so we get to check out the flagship
store which is actually really exciting
because that like I don't know anything
about k-beauty and also I'm so eager to
learn about everything that they have
here so I'm just I'm excited to learn
but this place already looks so family
and then it's funny because Kacie and
Isaac are kind of being dragged to this
thing today because of mama Lula
you're being dragged to this whole
Korean beauty day because of me tomorrow
is when we get to do it kpop stuff but
today it's Mama's Day okay okay you know
I'm really looking forward to the most
though is getting some actual skin care
products for myself so I have been very
very very extremely blessed and lucky to
have decently good skin because I didn't
grow up having acne or any of that stuff
but I've also been very bad and taking
care of my skin like for years and years
and years I would go to sleep with my
makeup on like I rarely would wash my
face like I just I've been really bad in
taking care of myself and somehow the
gods have blessed me with decently good
spit but now that I'm getting older it
is all catching up to me and I'm getting
like a lot of sunspots and just these
dark circles I will never go away and
I've also been getting like a lot of
little bumps on my face which I have
been going to my facial girl cherry and
she's been burning them off so like I
have all I used to have all these little
like spots under my eyes which you could
see in our wedding video I don't know
how to get rid of them other than
burning them off and it's really it's a
really painful process so like I said
it's all catching up to me after all
these years of not taking care of my
skin so today I'm eager to learn what
the Korean skin regimen is like and
getting myself some decent products and
actually going through with taking care
of myself because recently I think in
the last year I've actually been real
good about washing my face every night
taking my makeup off putting moisturizer
and eye cream but I know that there's
like a million other things I could
possibly be doing to improve my skin
which I am hoping to learn about today
because my skin like the complexion of
my skin is just all blotchy without
makeup so I would like to get that even
and does not have to worry about those
weird bumps that show up every day I
don't know I don't know what they are
ever tell you my tree-huggers story I
think I did we probably forgot but I
remember one time I was in Mexico and I
went up to what I thought was a tree and
I started hugging it and then my mom
starts laughing my mom and dad and they
were like why are you hugging that I'm
like what I love I love the earth I love
the environment in the world I start
laughing they're like me hey that's not
a tree that's a pole I started it felt
so dumb because that was literally the
first tree that I hugged ever and it
wasn't even a tree I was like damn
that's embarrassing and for a long time
my family would make fun of me saying
that was a pole hugger but at least you
got it right this is actually a tree so
good for you I know maybe like a URI kid
you only see you think that a certain
height and yeah such a micro angle and
that's so much
like it's like blowing up your parent
and hugging them and then looking up I
saw Julie all right what it all is a lot
like on the second floor and I thought I
saw Julia so I was it like there's
something there someone Aaron wasn't in
Japan it was someone else
uh-huh you're like Polly brand somebody
else yeah and then after I want to go
and hug this girl I like blue hair I
look like Julia and I want to go baby
UNIX on Julia did you tell her what
happened
no that is so funny so you just scared a
random Japanese girl that's hilarious
see you are totally my son
all right so surplus ooh
this brand is a high-end brand because
their main ingredient that they use for
their cosmetics is ginseng and if you
guys know anything about ginseng is that
it's very expensive in Korean are famous
for having ginseng and so that's why
this specific product is so expensive
and high-end because of the fact that
they use that ingredient and other stuff
I honestly I'm trying to pretend like I
know what I'm talking about but I really
don't and today I'm gonna learn I
promise guys
okay so I've learned a little bit more
as to why ginseng is very important and
it's because it has great anti-aging
components or properties so that's why
this skin care product is very very
popular because it's anti-aging and I
just thought it was the kids that they
have like an entire wrapping service so
if you want if you buy a certain amount
of products then you get to have these
cute little things get wrapped for free
and it's like very artistic and it just
makes for a really good present
intense Mother's Day thank you so now
we're checking out the rooftop look how
gorgeous honestly I don't think the
camera is doing this justice cuz it
looks really cool in person or maybe
with Casey's fancy camera cuz it's huge
he's been using this really nice camera
is getting all cinematic with with the
b-roll so hopefully you guys are
enjoying these vlogs look at you did
you're really enjoying this place living
the good life oh there's the mirror over
there I'm like hey she looks familiar
[Music]
that never happened
alright guys it's the most exciting time
of the day for me it's and I'm leaving
the boys behind so I don't know what
they're gonna do all I know is that I'm
going to be really clean
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so this is my room I'm so
excited
ah okay so they told me that well first
of all here's the row and I got to
change it to those underwear slippers
there's a shower so they told me that
they were speaking with these foot
massage the flex grub and then they're
gonna move on to my back I'm gonna get
like a body massage with my back and
then
I'm gonna get a facial and they're gonna
be using ginseng product to do it the
early anti-aging type of facial and I am
just so I'll see you guys after all
right Isaac what are we doing right now
[Music]
because we're right here I know we
actually worried we didn't really have a
chance we're so busy there we didn't
really have a chance to go around
shopping and surprise our right
[Music]
thankful skin some skincare products
[Music]
oh my gosh
no way would you get me that's just the
free sampler stuff well I don't want to
mess up the beautiful packaging oh yeah
you should see that we could open it
when we get back get back home yeah get
back to the okay okay so that was
awesome they did this foot scrub thing
and they use hot ginseng like a ginseng
type of like a or something and like she
was scrubbing might be right that right
so that's how it started
and then I moved over to the massage
table and it she was really getting into
that into like the knots like she was
really working why not usually I'm
really sensitive to massages and I
really like them light but this one was
like perfect amount of pressure and I
really feel like tomorrow I'm gonna feel
like jello like just refreshed and then
she started doing my facial and she was
using she said she was using a lot of
like ginseng products so like anti-aging
facial it was really relaxing and
amazing she even did like a scout
massage and like she was combing my hair
with some brush that was I felt amazing
it was just I kept feeling the blood
circulation she kept stimulating the
blood circulation and then towards the
end she starts putting this mask on my
face and I don't know where I start
getting this insane coffee tack and I
could not stop coughing like she
actually hadn't removed the mass that
she put on I was like I'm so sorry
you know just could not stop coughing so
she ran out and got me some water she
came back I drink some water
and then she put the mask on again and
then again I got a closet at home like
damn it
like what why right now like it's the
whole time I was doing great but I guess
because I was faced up like the mucus
and my sinuses I don't know like it went
down and like tickle with my throw-up in
my lungs or something I don't know but I
was so bummed out that I could not
control my cough and right she actually
left me for she said five minutes she
was like over five minutes your your
mask will be done so she ended up
leaving me but I honestly feel like I
scared her off because I couldn't coffee
and then since there was a shower in the
room I was wondering like wait can I
take a shower or are they gonna need
this room right away
everyone's waiting for me maybe I
shouldn't shower so I just ended up
putting my hair up and I'm gonna be
makeup free for the rest of the day
because I didn't bring my makeup so
enjoy this bare face for the rest of the
day it was so cool she was doing this
one thing where she kind of did
grabbed my face slightly she's gonna be
teaching it I don't know just doing a
lot of cool stuff where I'm like hey
awesome thanks for the fomo description
well there's some other time I think
right
[Music]
all right so we're back at the hotel and
I am so excited I want to see what my
friend like one would you guys get me
all right so we got you some dark circle
stuff cuz I'm getting old
dang it just kidding no I appreciate it
this is a trick conversation yeah cuz I
was complaining about me having new
wrinkles now that I'm getting closer to
30 okay oh look at this beautifully
wrapped yeah that cuz we saw this i'ma
split loser then we saw this you're like
oh he'll yes oh I got it that's all Wow
look at that those the box and source
ooh you're the cinematic camera
all right let's switch over cinematic
camera remembering this is the
exfoliating mask this is what you used
to scrub off dead skin to start a
process of anti-aging I like this little
brush thing remember we're playing with
it in the store yeah and now I
Donkey Kong Country we're so excited to
do this thing now you're over it
bond it out to me it wasn't like I think
that I would replay Wow what did you
offer me what if your mom was like that
24/7 mm-hmm I love it Oh tuck to wild
thank you
[Music]
was it smaller it smells like ginseng
ooh oh my god I'm so excited to stay on
forever
good morning I think is not having a
very good morning I know tell my baby
all right so if you want the beginning
of today all you stayed up watching
Netflix till like 2:00 last night after
we got home and after we showed you guys
everything that they bought for me for
my Mother's Day present we actually
knocked up pretty quickly after that
like Casey and I were dead and then
Isaac stayed up watching Netflix and I
remember waking up at midnight and
telling Isaac like dude go to sleep it's
midnight like what are you doing he's
like I can't go to sleep and then I was
just too sleepy and tired till I get him
to go to sleep so I just knocked out and
then I woke up again at 2:00 a.m. and
I'm like listen I don't care that you
can't go to sleep you need to put away
that laptop you need to go to sleep
you're gonna have a bad day tomorrow and
now he's exhausted
so mama knows that baby I listen to you
too like so what about today though
today you're singing you're gonna learn
how to sing some k-pop songs you're
gonna make your own album you're gonna
be radio a studio exec set the place
we're going scouting what if you sign
you write today
no you're good run yes so today like I
said Isaac it's gonna be learning how to
sing is gonna be creating his own album
I don't want to say
like a little baby it's okay all right
yeah so then after that we're all gonna
learn how to do a kpop dance and it's
gonna be the BTS boy with love
I saw them perform this song Ian and SNL
so when I heard it and even when I was
watching it that first thing I was just
like damn this thing is catchy like I
couldn't stop coming it the rest of the
day so I'm like no wonder they're
worldwide popular like it's just I don't
know what's in the music but it really
is very catchy hold baby I wish I could
fill in for you and sing instead of you
singing since you're saying you don't
really want to do it but my voice is
jacked up there's no way I could be able
to sing today and daddy's voice is
pretty messed up too so it's all up to
you to make the family look good I'm
just kidding pressure her that rhythm
moniker and energetic so I was gonna be
singing and recording his album winner
miss Dianna are you ready to be a kpop
star today I've never sang like a Korean
song before I'm very nervous it's the
morning so bad for vocals it's ignorance
- I think no shirt team's here she was
watching you you gotta perform
so our extra k-pops thought use the same
microphone and you're going to use it
today
[Music]
one more time I'm not giving you try one
more time so we can double it okay
[Music]
you're one you're too good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
does it rapping in Korean oh god no
Kumar k2 konic ooh
Tomiko Varkey narrator while hiking my
hair okay okay not for all right okay yo
icicle are you ready
yep I'm ready uh iced tea I see yeah
let's go yo icicle you ready yep
sweet I see I stay in the house I school
in the house let's spend some hot fire
okay let's go they go fetch my gorilla
honestly I want to do this like really
bad so I'm saving their pamphlets stuff
and next time we're in Seoul I'm
definitely booking a session coming back
I really really really would love to do
a song and critic is actually walking
through how to pronounce it in Korean
and so I just wanted like to hear myself
you know do an actual kpop song in
Korean and I would love to do it if I
had a proper voice miss Dianna you did
so good it was cringes no you did so
great
honestly I am so bummed out that my
voice is so crappy because I wish I
could have joined you guys I feel like
your voice to be super psyche as a
rapper really kind of raspy like and
then all in Korean down amazing that's
true well too late you guys are done you
did great good job baby
we do deep voice it was good
icicle nose all right so now we're at
the dance studio we're gonna be learning
how to dance
the song that I think in this Tiana
saying earlier so it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we just finished our dance class I feel
like I don't think I can recreate this
without him in the room with me because
I was literally following his steps but
every time I tried to complete an entire
song
I kept butchering it towards like
certain spot so I'm like oh man and then
not only that but I couldn't help but
just think about the way I looked in the
mirror and I'm like holy cow
when did this happen when did I gain so
much weight I need to go home and work
out like that's all I was thinking in my
head so it was really hard for me to
focus on the moves but it's also like
I'm not very coordinated I guess like
I've never really done well when I have
to follow other moves like people like
aerobics class I was always the worst
so I'm actually kind of proud of how
much I was able to retain and
regurgitate with my body so that was
pretty fun but now I'm all sweaty how
was it for you guys you're working out
now you can actually sing and perform
the song that you learned today so how'd
you feel I feel productive productive
force away oh that's your go-to where
were you it was very similar to some
Michael Jackson accents that I used to
imitate when I was younger so this is
cool
yeah they never realized how tiring it
could be of course you're moving a whole
body moves like you're just kind of
chill at home I never actually dance
class you're like going all out to the
beat yeah pushing you you're like I'll
stay on be you know in the mic and it's
like really laughs you know
[Laughter]
you look like a gangster
Oh the way he has stripped but so are
you a BTS fan now that you know they use
Michael Jackson moves yeah I know me too
actually I kind of want to go home and
play
BTS now and actually learn the lyrics
[Music]
all right now we're gonna check out the
lots of tower
look at that it's the tallest tower in
South Korea and apparently is the third
largest or tallest tower in the world so
that's pretty impressive the tallest one
is just fine yeah tell us one is in
Dubai if Tina baby so while we had free
time I went shopping and I bought a
whole bunch of new clothes I love when
we visit different countries we get to
see the regular stores that we have at
home but they actually sell different
styles of clothing so in Korea I'm
really diggin the fashion actually I'm
wearing what I bought yesterday where
are you today super cute I love it so I
bought some more stuff today even though
it's like from H&M and Hollister and I
haven't seen the style I mean maybe they
do have them back home but I haven't
came across any of this the style that I
bought today at home so I was like I'm
fine whatever I can fit in my luggage
and I'm probably not gonna be able to
fit everything that I got but I'll
figure it out I'll just buy another bag
or something
so now we're heading to the top of the
look that tower which after a quick
Google searches says it's the world's
fifth tallest tower
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]